[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
the friendly shippy on the in the
podcast
coming to you straight from these
leather chairs it's me mr billy boyd
it's me don monaghan here i've got a
little song for it dom oh go on
this is a podcast we do it every day
except for wednesdays thursdays fridays
saturdays sundays and mondays nice not
bad day i love that someone wants to
drop a little bit of edm edm put some
edms on it and release it we'll become
number one in amsterdam yeah maybe we'll
we'll play it on the podcast next week
now you recently had your car serviced
yeah how how are you as a
like generally with car stuff i've no
idea dom when i was a younger man
i i did try to fix a few things it
always went wrong but cars are now
hard to fix aren't they they look more
like computers and there's a lot of
computer stuff going used to be you put
the dip step and oh that's no good that
oil needs chain dip dip stick
stick hard to see i think
it's slightly frustrating isn't it when
you go to
the mechanic
mm-hmm
where they report back
because anything they could say anything
you know we found we thought it was just
going to be rotating your towers towers
yeah rotate the towers from the towers
we thought we're just going gonna have
to rotate the tires just change the oil
but unfortunately
the engine turned itself upside down
somehow yeah and somehow four and a half
thousand dollars the bangladesh has come
loose
that's another three grand yeah you must
have driven over the phalange at one
point yeah because that the whole tube's
falling out i drive a tesla and you
can't go anywhere apart from tesla to
get it serviced of course not and at
that point you're really in trouble not
only that but i was sent an image from a
friend who said that now
tesla itself yeah the car will tell you
when it needs new stuff so the car will
go up i need a couple of new tires if
you wouldn't mind owner so then you
self press self drive it takes you to
tesla has all your credit card
information
just scan your card sooner or
on the driveway until you later
back in the day
what was it wednesday by the way
what was your first car
well i used to drive my mom's that
doesn't count don't go so my first car
ever was a volkswagen polo
called orville did you see that like a
german person volkswagen dragon
volkswagen how much was it why would you
say volkswagen that's a volkswagen
is it volkswagen
got a little he was driving it when i
was away i think in new zealand actually
and he got a little light saying
we're low on oil change yeah change that
not gonna do that
and
the in the engine melted into just one
massive metallic block on the motorway
and it had to be put on a lorry to take
away and the car was completely totaled
just because matt wouldn't change he
just wouldn't change the iron
did i say anything no i bet you did no i
didn't i bet you did i absolutely did i
said hey that's fine do you think it's
just a car isn't it matt how much did it
cost no it's totally you remember though
when you bought it how much it cost yeah
i want well i'm gonna say
about four thousand pounds that's all
right what was your first weight your
first car had holes in the floor yeah it
did it was down it was a mazda three
and it did have holes in the car in the
bottom and when it rained which it does
a lot in glasgow
the water all came in through the the
floor and you would just be standing in
a puddle
what's the coolest guy i've ever been in
we thought well i'd love to have this
um
not really a car person me
i drove a lamborghini for a while as a
loner
would have did i ever see you when i
drove that lamborghini yeah we went in
at once it's very problematic
it just felt like you were an attractor
it's extremely low to the ground so if
you go over a speed bump or what we call
a sleeping policeman which i think is a
great name for it much better name for
it
uh it would clank clan clan clan and
also you don't want to park it anywhere
no and you don't want the valet people
to park it because they're going to ruin
it
and no one lets you out in traffic
because you just think
[ __ ]
i'll tell you how cool cara was in just
remembered kenny baker
who's out tonight hey dude good to see
you i'll do a great can you make a
confession i love you see you really
jump in my rose darling
good kenny baker i love kenny baker
yeah he doesn't like he's big no no he
was lovely
he's a rolls-royce right i was in kenny
baker's rolls-royce great guy the
stories he could tell and he had to have
blocks on uh pedals to reach them yeah
but
amazing yeah amazing big rolls royce he
drove around beautiful what i loved
about kenny bacon whenever you saw him
was he lived his life didn't he oh yeah
i'm gonna buy rolls-royce
massive slap up meals i'm gonna enjoy
myself laughing joking socializing it's
a lovely life i'll sleep wherever i want
yeah it's just used to fall asleep and
restaurants yeah great lovely men hey
listen we don't have that much time to
get into uh you know just tomfoolery
here because we're getting into the
second part
of what i think is going to turn into an
iconic interview someone said aston in a
jungle somewhere the greater of the two
parts the second part of the shawn aston
friendship onion interview now you and i
got to know sean astin during the lord
of the rings trilogy and since then
we've spent some time with him on the
convention circuit
and also
just in general sean astin likes to
do quite a bit of housekeeping to make
sure that everyone's okay doesn't it
yeah he's quite big checking in on
people everybody all right having a good
holiday is this good
been your birthday are you good yeah you
near me i'm going here i'm on the east
coast are you on the east coast are we
hanging out
lovely man sean astin so this is the
second part of our
chat with the wonderful sean and we will
see you
after that
you and elijah had a very
close intense special relationship you
taking care of elijah the whole samwise
frodo thing very intense you and billy
got on very well but i was saying to
billy last week when we were leaving i
said i wonder if sean is interested in
exploring this idea that you know you
and i had a couple of little moments of
tension didn't we on a few days where we
were like oh [ __ ] off and you'd be like
oh well maybe you [ __ ] off too you
remember that
i remember a couple with uh
andy
right remember you you accident no andy
accidentally pulled your wig off right
yeah yeah just you know he he was
supposed to grab us and pull us and the
wig it was actually a weird cloak like
it was it wasn't the normal cloak it had
like super big hood or something and he
he grabbed it and it just ripped my wig
off so i was mostly embarrassed at that
moment but um
but no like little like where was little
i don't know maybe i don't know yeah no
i mean nothing more than
yeah nothing more than little tiny
moments of i think
the the day that we did the wooded log
thing where we had the the
the
different invertebrates coming out of
the ground i had i had the spider on my
hand and i remember you saying to me how
are you going to do it and i said i'm
going to do it like this i'm going to
have it crawl over my hand and walk this
way and you said would you not think
it's better if you do it like this and i
said well i've been told by the guy that
i need to do like this and we you and i
had a little moment then nothing too
hectic but you know those
we're we're in such different places as
mary and as sam throughout those movies
i wonder if there was some of that going
on you know
we i mean
we always
you cannot possibly work together as
closely as people like us work together
and not have moments where you
yeah step on step on each other a little
bit nothing nothing jumps out at me i
mean i i remember in that moment we were
supposed to scoop back into that little
hole and i'm like fat
and i'm like
can i get my
fat body in there i'm not i can't be
like you know mister
you know there's no elegance involved in
moving into position so i but but no i
don't i don't i don't really remember no
there's nothing like look i'm sure like
you said it happens with everyone i i
can be extremely irritating i'm sure i
got on billy's nerves quite a lot yeah
quite a lot still dude you're supposed
to at that point say no no no no never
never
i don't ever remember seeing you i never
remember seeing you two get on each
other's nerves for a moment we've we've
only had one crossword and it was about
league of legends
which you're going to start playing
right sean
yeah yeah i i started looking it up
yesterday it's uh it looks it looks okay
it looks okay you'll like it elijah
elijah just did the tutorial he's going
to jump in we'll have all four hobbits
playing at the same time it'll be an
epic moment it's going to be that's a
reason
yes so here's the tom i remember oh go
on go on john
no i was just going to say i you i
remember you your patience
really i remember
i just remember
thinking i could see you choosing to be
patient
with you know choosing a situation
whatever whatever nonsense was happening
whatever
you know whatever amount of time or the
logistics or whatever it was i could
just i could just see you
i i i remember admiring it and thinking
i didn't have it the ability in certain
moments to be patient the way i saw you
be patient i appreciate that very much
sean i'm not necessarily known for my
patients and certainly about them wasn't
known for my patients i honestly think
probably more than anything else
i was having so much fun
making those films and unfortunately due
to a few things that were going on with
you you probably weren't as in the fun
zone as i was i remember thinking even
on days off i would rather be on set
working with all my friends and having
fun
than having an extra day you know you
had ali you wanted to spend time with
you with your daughter who's changing
and growing every day i was
at home on my own i'd rather be with you
guys
you were going to say something bills
oh no i was just going to say i always
enjoyed
sean's company i find and i still do i
find you intriguing as a character and
uh i i like your i like your passion for
things i like your passion for
like if we're even if we're talking
about british theater or literature i
always enjoy
because i i like your passion for things
but the the one time that it
it just accelerated
tenfold
as i was i was in a hotel room jet
lagged
and i think i've told you this story
well i must have done and i was watching
tv and i saw a movie just about to start
with you in it and i thought oh watch
this and it was rudy
i'd never seen rudy
and you you must remember this
for a month after that i called you rudy
because
i thought the film was amazing i thought
your performance was amazing i just
everything about that just kind of
escalated you in every way for me
because i thought it was a it was such a
beautifully measured if you looked at it
as an actor it was wonderful
and and just as a story was wonderful
and
i called you rudy for about a month
after that because i i like that it's so
weird that i had never saw the film and
knew nothing about it as a british guy i
suppose it wasn't a big thing in britain
i don't know it wasn't it wasn't very
successful in america either for it it
grew an audience
in the
like in the
late 90s early 2000s it started to
develop an audience and by the time
you know it it ended up becoming pretty
popular and and pretty well known um you
know doing commercials for
during football
big football games and stuff like that
but no for a long time it was it was
actually the studio thought it was
unsuccessful i would say or it's a big
disappointment so
when you did that film
21 i just got married i got married
pretty young yeah you did just got
married
yes this is indiana right near where my
wife is from and insane love from us
yeah give him a little time
they're excited that i'm seeing you oh
that's cool what was your favorite
restaurant in wellington new zealand
what a great question
i'm remembering the favorite dish right
oh even better surely
now wait sean for a second your favorite
dish wasn't in your favorite restaurant
well
i i remember the dish
go on talk us through it
did it have bok choy in it because i
remember new zealand was absolutely
crazy for bok choy do you remember when
we were there no i hate a bit well
what they put on their pizzas stop
putting peaches and goat's cheese with
caramelized onions no no
tomato sauce
cheese mushrooms and maybe a jalapeno
yeah that's what's on my pizza sorry
sorry
what was the dish talking about i'm not
gonna have it
well it was uh so i've you know for the
last year and a half up until about two
weeks ago i've been vegan
and then i had a and then i had a steak
but there was some sort of uh
some sort of a um
hold on is it burgundy on is it like
beef beef burgers
it was just really rich and it was uh
thick buttery gravy
yeah
moist in the mouth
yeah what was that where was it the
white house was where was
yeah the white house yeah yeah it was
the white house i knew it'd be the white
house he loved the white house he got
very excited now would you as a starter
in the white house would you have those
oysters that were done in the oven oh
patrick
let's just kill patrick
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something that's interfering
with your happiness or maybe preventing
you from achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
and you can start communicating with
them in under 48 hours
there's a broad range of expertise which
may not be available in many areas and
this service is available for clients
worldwide
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life
today visit their website and read the
testimonials that are posted daily
visit betterhelp.com
that's better
h-e-l-p
and join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counsellors all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
hey are you feeling a little stressed
anxious or maybe you've got a niggling
pain
well me and dom i've got something for
you
feels
cbd
feels offer a premium cbd that will keep
your head clear
and help you feel your best
sometimes i'll take uh some cbd
you know in the evening when you want to
wind down and you've had a big day
and it just helps you get in that nice
place where you're ready for a good
night's sleep
all you need to do is put a few drops of
fuels under your tongue and you'll feel
the difference in minutes
now it's not
cbd isn't about what you feel
it's about what you don't feel stress
anxious that niggling pain
if you join fuels monthly membership
they'll make the self-care easy you'll
save money on every order and you can
pause and cancel at any time
start feeling better with feels become a
member today
by going to feels.com onion and you'll
get 50
off your first order and free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash onion to
become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping fields dot com slash
onion
it sounds like he's hurling some epithet
at the scottish guy yes
sorry patrick
you just keep shooting
i remember the four of us i don't have a
great memory but i remember the four of
us sitting in that restaurant and eating
oysters kilpatrick and having a great
night a great one what about you you've
not said what your favorite restaurant
in wellington was
i really like that um was it indonesian
that's mine do you remember the name of
it
you've stolen my restaurant i don't
remember that i don't remember the name
of it what was it copy yeah copy i used
to love copy
wow and sometimes we would even get copy
delivered to the set which
yeah yeah we get a little that was
fantastic do you remember elijah
elijah and i got uh japanese food
delivered yes the japanese restaurant
what was that called the japanese for 10
points i think i remember i'll let sean
go first
i want to say like cure something
i don't know
you want to say that or you will see it
yeah i want to say well i'm not going to
say because i know it's wrong but i want
to say it so i want credit for venturing
a thought i'll give you a clue sean
it was something sushi and the something
in front of it was a japanese word
aragato sushi i don't think it was
arigatou says right okay but do you
notice billy
billy does this thing quite a lot shaun
and you have to watch him with this
because he will do it with you at a
convention he'll claim that he knows the
answer to something and then when you
get the answer right he'll go correct
answer and you go did you know that and
he'll go no i didn't know that actually
i i have no idea is the name of the
sushi restaurant i want to say an elijah
problem go on
kabayashi no i think it's a dish i'm
taking my sock off because there's
detritus underneath my socket i'm gonna
go i think it was a dish a sushi dish
and i want to say you keep saying dish
i want to say that the name of the sushi
restaurant in wellington was
unagi sushi
he just switched his computer off with
his youtube i think that's right it's so
disgusting i think it was called
that's right
and i'd probably elijah and i probably
had
sushi from there and we would get
teriyaki chicken and maybe
maybe four times a week yeah months
our friend nigel nelly uh new zealand uh
kiwi nigel nelly who's working on magnum
pi in hawaii and plays league of legends
with us the only reason why i'm giving
all that information aways because he
said please don't say my name because
people are calling me a nerd at work so
nigel nelly working at uh
on magnum nigel in hawaii yeah nigel
nelly yeah at that point
was um a runner on lord the rings and i
remember him telling me that he
would get a request from
elijah for sushi or teriyaki chicken and
he would go and get it and then when he
brought it back one of the other three
hobbits would see it and say oh can we
have that too and he go yeah okay i'll
go get that and then he'd come back and
the other hobbit would sit and go oh can
i have that and he would go four times
backwards and forwards to the same sushi
restaurant which he did not appreciate
hi nigel and it was fun
it was far away yeah it was right in the
center it was far it was on it was on
the far side of uh it was from sea
tuning you got to go all the way to the
far side of wellington i think did you
live you lived in seaton the whole time
when you were in wellington yeah we
yeah well at first we went and we moved
in what was um what's the name of the
newspaper the national just the
wellington or something is it good
for 10 points
herald the new zealand herald
i think it's a willing wellington
gazette i don't know
they had an old building from like their
initial building in the 60s or something
50s or 60s and we stayed in there and
that was
terrifying why
ghosts well
well no go son of underwine ghosts i
know you are bigger you're a big one of
ghosts but no the uh because earthquakes
are big in wellington and the
way those buildings are built you just
feel it
going like this
even you have to put on a good face room
so you you get out of there with the you
you had the fear that there was going to
be
an earthquake to that would bring down
that building
it was an old building yeah nothing
that's been
nothing that's been brought down
was brought down before it was brought
down it's a great great exactly
when he's right when it's up it's up
yeah
but when it's only halfway down
so
so you moved out
but just in case
no it was quite drafty actually and so
it was it wasn't
yeah right it wasn't the right spot to
be but they found us this house
uh they found us a house at the top of
sea tune the very very top right and it
was you remember you remember right it
was kind of yeah the guy who built it he
the owner built it himself and it was
it had things in it that i'd never seen
before like heated coils underneath the
bathroom tile right the
you know you could flip a switch and
then when you go in there
from your feet it was well the wind
that's what was a
say again you would burn your feet
you could if it was poorly made or
electrocute yourself a thought that did
occur to me but no as it turned out it
was perfectly safe
um it was actually at the mouth of the
um the inlet that so
so
uh
wellington
it looks like you're looking out at the
ocean but you're actually looking out at
a big bay and the big bay kind of turns
to the right as you look
out and that's where the ship's coming
out to the cook straight and we were our
house overlooked the entrance from the
cook straight in there so we would see
these massive massive tankers you know
container ships coming in and out of all
the time and it was really mesmerizing
and wonderful and the wind windy
wellington and where we were was the
windiest it doesn't get any windier than
where we were and you were just sure the
house was going to blow away but i
wasn't so worried about that
interestingly oh that's so here's here's
a scary thing that a story you might not
have heard of me and dom
in the cooks straight we were learning
how to scuba dive
when we had a couple of weeks off
and part of the the um
the thing that you had to do to get your
certificate qualification qualification
as me and dom had to do like a dive
together where we told the guy where
we're going to go how we're going to get
there
what we're going to do and get back
again
and so we mapped out this thing that
went to like an old um a sunk ship
so we had to get to the sunk ship have a
look around head back to where the guy
was
so me and dom were just swimming for
like 40 minutes and he told us watch the
cook straight because if you get too far
into that current you'll end up in
antarctica it'll suck you right off
so me and dom are down there
swimming for like honestly about 40
minutes and i'm running out of air and
i'm like where is this boat and we're
trying to talk to each other under with
all the things that we'd learned you
know
and i said i'm gonna have to go up
and i went up and we were nowhere near
yeah we
like the beach was about two miles away
and we were out in the cook street
and i was like i don't have any air i'm
gonna have to so i had to swim back on
the surface with all the waves while dom
was down like swimming in the kind of
relative calm yeah i got on my back
flipped onto my back on the bottom of
the water and watched you swimming above
me
and when we got back the guy said so
everything go okay we're like yeah yeah
we got to the thing yeah and they gave
us the certificate so we're all kids
also while we were while we were doing
some of our qualification in the
swimming pool we're down at the bottom
billy and the the instructor says get
down to the bottom and just talk each
other through the equipment make sure
your tank is right and if you need to
readjust your bcd do all that kind of
stuff so we're doing all the stuff under
the water and billy
shows me his index finger and points to
it like that
and i think that for some reason what
he's saying to me is come sit on my
index finger i said no no no i'm not
going to do that he said no why would
you think that point he points at me you
come sit on this thing i said no
it's called the witch
wish wishful thinking i said no i'm not
under the water i said no absolutely not
i'm not gonna do that i said come on
we'll have to we have to go up because i
need to talk to you about sitting on my
index finger so i get to the top and i
say billy that's not part of the class
me sitting on the units he said no no
i'm trying to find out if the depth
perception is different on the wall i
wanted you to touch my index
so what i'm getting out of this first of
all as is hand signals yes
but i'm also getting out of this that
dom's mind goes to a kind of like base
sexual thing whereas billy wants
something much more intimate and yeah
and close yeah
yeah i like to know if he could
interesting yeah it might be right
although i think billy was a little bit
of a dark horse
filming the the lord of the rings
trilogy because without giving yourself
away bills
how many members of the fellowship have
you kissed on the mouth i've kissed a
few of the fellowship would you would it
be fair to say
six i would think at least six yeah so
who's the dirty dog can i just clarify
who was the first
uh
you you were the first john you looked
in that little sword fencing show that
we did
that finished with a kiss as i remember
it that's lovely yeah i set the bar
very high for the rest of the fellowship
i know you kissed um
viggo during the uh wedding scene the
sam and rosie wedding scene oh yeah he
was quite aggressive
yeah do you remember that he just
grabbed me and kissed me i think timmy
fairvigo kissed you didn't you wasn't it
yeah yeah you were being kissed
you know that yeah he wanted to see what
all the fuss was about yeah
we hold it
billy and dom eat the world
well sean we have we have a regular
feature on our show which is uh mine and
billy's favorite part of the show which
is called billy billion doll meet the
world and we we very often ask our guest
if they will give us a suggestion you
had suggested uh quite a fancy welsh
rare bit which i vetoed do you remember
i hang on so welsh
my mother would make for me every uh
uh new year's eve but i did not suggest
welsh rare oh you didn't suggest i no i
discovered
and it would have been the first time
ever making
scotch rare bit oh what was the
difference
uh well the welsh rabbit uses a dark be
a dark beer a guinness kind of you know
a darker beer right
heavy yeah and then uh and well you can
just imagine what the scotch one would
be instead of the beer it's uh is there
whiskey there it is
yeah
it's a whiskey yeah
well we vetoed that because it felt it
felt like it was going to be a little
bit too much hard labor for john our
producer and also all you need is a
bunsen burner mate
i don't think john would be a very good
cook do you know no i don't can you tell
just by looking at him he doesn't look
as if he'd be very good at cooking stuff
the the rare bit is is very very very
easy it's like flour and cheese and
whatever and you just put it in the
thing and mix it up and you that's it
you just set it on the flame
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is real
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with mushroom for productivity
and immune support
now
i've been starting my day with four
sigmatics ground mushroom coffee and i
tell you what i feel like i'm more
productive i'm getting a lot of stuff
done plus
it's easy on the gut and it doesn't
leave you with that horrible jittery
feeling
now you're probably thinking
does it taste like mushrooms no i can
guarantee it tastes like coffee i have
drunk a lot of coffee and it tastes like
beautiful
dark
nutty coffee
now we have worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling mushroom coffee but this is
just for the friendship onion listeners
get up to 40 off and free shipping on
mushroom coffee bundles
to claim this deal you must go to
foursigmatic.com
onion this offer is only for the
friendship onion listeners and is not
available on their regular website
you'll save up to 40 off and you get
free shipping so go right now to
f o u r
s i g
m a t i c dot com slash onion and fuel
your productivity and creativity with
some delicious mushroom coffee
so we often hear that the average adult
needs to sleep for between seven and
nine hours every night well sometimes
that is just not possible but the good
news is
research has shown
that quality is just as important as
quantity we need to get that deep sleep
so how do you get that deep sleep were
you waking up refreshed every morning
that's where chilly sleep comes in
chilly sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that help
improve your entire well-being
chili sleep makes the euler and cube
sleep systems hydro powered temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
your ideal sleep temperature so you get
that deep sleep and waking up refreshed
head over to chillysleep.com
onion to learn more
and you can save 20 percent of the
purchase of any new sleep system
this offer is only available to the
friendship onion listeners and only for
a limited time that's chile
c-h-i-l-i
sleep.com
slash onion to take advantage of our
exclusive discount and wake up refreshed
every day
well we did not do that we'll do that
next time instead we did something else
do you want to tell us what you
suggested john well johnny brings in
the food item uh yes so that when i
decided since you weren't going to let
me go with an elegant uh you know uh
culinary
thing i thought i would bring you um i
know you're both uh well i know dom is
very athletic quite athletic with the
with the soccer oh yeah we both are yeah
the footy
all right billy is as well but i
remember how aggressive you were when we
were first playing that's the first time
i saw your aggression is when we played
in that that uh oh yeah anyhow this is
called big league chew big league this
isn't
yeah it's probably made in taiwan or
something but
oh look it's uh
look at all the things that it doesn't
have and it doesn't have gluten it
doesn't have peanuts doesn't have a
little bit
what it is
uh
so
baseball players yeah it being the
national pastime and whatnot uh used to
uh chew tobacco and they would spit you
know you put a big wad of chewing
tobacco on your lip there and you'd spit
and the dugout which is
and it's in football and soccer they
have that weird kind of bus bench
looking thing yeah they did it baseball
there's a there's a proper dugout you go
down into the dugout and and uh it was
always filled with the most disgusting
you know two inch layer of uh
of
spit of tobacco spit right so at a
certain point children wanted to get in
on the game so they designed a gum to
look
like chewing tobacco right and that kids
could uh yeah
so i i got it for its thematic resonance
and not for its um
would you have grown up with this sean
yeah are you what when did they bring
this out oh women like sean's already
got it in his mouth sean's settle down
are you a fan of this john did you grow
up with this as a kid
as a little kid it's like when you get
pretend cigarettes when you're six years
old or five years old than their candy
and you and you blow on it a little bit
of uh
powdered sugar comes out of it and you
feel like you're like your mother who
smoked three packs a day yeah but um
yeah so um yeah i know this definitely
had the look and feel
that the big leaguers had they always
had their chew and a thing like in a
packet like this and you open it up and
you could always see it looked you know
yeah so it's bubble gum now they have a
similar type of bubble gum that comes in
a roll that
says hit big league big league chew has
sold more than 800 million pouches and
is designated in the hall of fame bubble
gum wow
well
i'm going to it smells very give it a
chance does everyone get grape i've got
grape
does look like chewing tobacco right
here we go here we go
i'm putting a big chunk in my box are
you putting a big chunk you shouldn't
you want to have that
[Music]
flavor
mastication the thing that's gross about
it is the powder they use to keep it
from sticking to the tin foil
it's really quite gross
oh wow
do you chew gum on a regular basis on
it's supposed to be quite good for
concentration
i'll tell you the only time that i chew
gum and it happens every single time
that i do it is when i go surfing i chew
gum because i don't like that frothy
spit that you get when you get too much
sea water in your mouth but if you chew
gum
you don't get it now billy's going to do
for them
you can do it when you're surfing and
you guys are the surfers i just know
this from having trained for a triathlon
close your mouth oh good [ __ ] just stop
the sea water from getting that's a good
shout out
the other great quality that this has is
it loses its flavor very quickly so you
have to keep putting more in until it's
a ball and then you have to find some
place to spit it out yeah
i mean it's quite a good flavor to be
honest right billy read something truly
dynamic about this product 40 years
later
than what 40 years later than what i
don't know john doesn't tell us johnny
and uh come on johnny
he starts off
the recon
with all our quotes and it just says 40
years later come on john then what
oh god okay
just a moment of silence there bill for
the chewing gum is that what i want just
a moment
to be reference reverential about the
gum itself right rob nelson ah good old
robbie a lefty hurler
while earning a degree
in philosophy at cornell university what
states that and dump i don't know but
that's where clarice starling went she
went to cornell
where's cornell sean
well i want to say connecticut but i'm
probably wrong what do they specialize
in do they specialize in
some law call now or is that wrong
i'll tell you what
sometimes john's
in ithaca new york
is that
john's m
obviously is sometimes like quite vague
these are the most vague and weird ones
he's ever he just copied he simply copy
and pasted it from the internet and he
there's no one how they all start 40
years later
and then without seeing who or anything
came up with the idea yeah yeah i mean
this is absolute nonsense john later on
it says didn't want to chew tobacco who
didn't want to chew tobacco john
wait let's have a look at january
january 1979
i read an article who did john did come
on john i read an article about a small
make your own bubble gum company of
arlington texas
i bought a case of this stuff
i went to the major supermarket and got
flavor extracts of maple and root beer
on february 6 1979 i made my first batch
of what would become big league too
i baked it and backed by judfield's
mum's kitchen
that's an interview with rob nelson
now sean you're a baseball fan don't
look at the product the package what is
what is significant about the date
february 6th in the world of baseball
billy don't give him a clip
can you give me a decade can you give me
a decade oh i don't know because i don't
know when
arranged i'll tell i'll give you a
little okay
well there you go
it's babe ruth's birthday sean asked him
for 10 points
well done so the the gum was first
they do it they did a first swing at the
gum
on february 6 1979 which is babe ruth's
birthday back in the day we're getting
more facts from the back of the gum
thing john then we got in your your
printout there is there is a good fact
about todd field the film staggering
number oh yeah how many they've sold
short shoulder millions sean will like
this because there's a john tell sean
the uh fact about todd phillips yeah so
so todd field is a filmmaker
nominated well first he was in eyes wide
shut he played the piano player in the
stanley kubrick's movie he's a little
pianist and he uh
he was he made in the bedroom one of my
favorite movies
and uh he was nominated for best picture
and best adapted screenplay and he was
friends with rob nelson uh i believe in
oregon somewhere
and basically he was chewing licorice
and he said hey todd
rob nelson said hey todd what do you
have there he said
uh it's not chewing tobacco it's not red
man it's just licorice and rob nelson
went todd field that's genius
yeah we should i'm gonna make gum that's
like chewing tobacco but it's gum
that's where it came from love that
just so you know there are a few colors
in here bills red 40 lake and blue one
lake
sean i was saying a few weeks ago that i
would love
to travel around the world to the
factories that make
all of the e numbers and the food
colorings and find out the different
processes wouldn't that be fascinating
so my my grandfather was the head of the
bureau of standards
basically
it's the government agency that decides
what weight is
right like what is an ounce
so they have like
if i'm not mistaken an ounce of a metal
locked
that's that's it but when when they're
trying to decide how much steel
you know a compressor can take on a
container ship or something like that
they go back to these weights and
measures the idea that you could go back
to where that red dye number six is yeah
that is that is a you might never eat
again yeah yeah i'm sure it would be
terrifying to find out where it came
from because some of the red food
coloring to go in and look at it yeah
there's a cochineal beetle that makes
the uh the red food coloring in some
some things and the cactuanal beetle is
exactly one ounce that's what they use
it's not a piece of metal it's a
cut-to-nail beetle are you blowing
bubbles over there yeah
10 calories so are you
in each serving
go on sean are we watching a serving
well deserving here there's eight
servings in this little bag here no it
says there's twenty just above it bill
the 27
it says the serving size is eight pieces
but i'm not sure what constitutes a
piece i suppose three grams three grams
of course so so this is the is this the
official bubble gum of the uh national
baseball league i don't know what
they've been doing for the last 40 years
this is this is little league
little kids chew this the big guys chew
um sunflower seeds i need to walk into a
dugout is that because there's a i don't
know a huge amount about baseball i live
with your brother for a while and he's a
massive dodgers fan i know you love the
dodgers too is that because of there's a
massive amount of nervous energetic
waiting in baseball is that where this
all comes from uh yeah
it's also the salt i think there's you
know when you're sitting out for such a
long period of time i don't know if some
of them have saltless seeds but you
can't sit in a dugout for three or four
innings and chew those things without
feeling like you're retaining water all
of a sudden so i don't know if that's
helpful for them on some level
but um but it's it's definitely the
it's boring
baseball i mean it's very exciting if
you really know what you're looking at
but there's an awful lot of time spent
sitting around and then punctuated by
moments of like ah now you gotta do
something crazy like
run 90 feet in sounds like acting second
yeah who's the guy sean who's the guy in
the cover in the c b
e
or c b l cap
c b l cap who is that guy in the front
is that
big league i think that's the guy from a
team
so tell me did you grow up eating this
is this something that when you taste it
it takes you back to a certain time an
easier time a more innocent time less
less helicopter time my uh yes my we
played
i played little league baseball which is
from the time you're probably
eight until i was 15.
it wasn't
we didn't have this a lot but this you
know occasionally you'd
somebody would have it it was always
great and exciting because it had sugar
i bet it had more sugar in it back then
oh yeah i better bet it had more sugar
back then but um
but yeah so it's it's sort of synonymous
with my childhood but the reason i chose
it for you lot
was because i think this is how you see
me
what
a
gum chewing baseball player yeah like an
american
playing baseball
yeah if you're not gonna let me do the
um
the uh rare bit the scotch rare bit then
you're gonna have to suffer
terribly because you remember sean there
was there was a period when we were all
getting our feet on that you used to
enjoy where
you used to shout out an american city
and billy and i would say the exact
opposite state that that city was in and
you and emergency to really enjoy that
states and capital yeah um i i i i don't
remember that but i'm sure it's true
well we vote we we we score these things
in three categories
oh the guy to my left here william boyd
will explain the categories there are
three categories sean
the first is taste
the second is this
aesthetic or look
and the third is usefulness
that's taste
aesthetic
and usefulness
so
and it's out of tension and you can use
decimal points if you like
example 6.2 it's a good example thank
you
hey that's a 10k that's 10k what's a 10k
race hey before we do that before we do
the thing then
will you do another
ironman i was just saying to christine i
don't want to think that i've done my
last iron man no you're going to do
another one come on
stop today she said i have to
i will i've been i've been trying i've
been i'm i've been trying to get there
it's really hard my body is doesn't pay
attention the way it should
she said i had to lose 40 pounds before
she would support it so that's a lot of
weight to lose foreign
let's do it then
we'll do it with you i really want to
no we won't
oh my god could you be my if well okay
we could do it in a relay i suppose
we'll cheer you i don't know what you're
uh no i will cheer you well that's it
okay well that's
would that be the reason we'd bring us
all together i mean that would be great
we could coach you there's a bunch of
money for jerry we'll coach him i need
coaching right okay we start today for
the taupo what when do you want to do it
next year
um
it's uh august now and it starts in
march so not enough time it'd have to be
in a year and a half yeah okay okay
we'll start the training right now 2023
okay iron man no more no more gum for
you sean that's your first note from the
from your trainers no more gum but let's
uh more than happy to take let's give it
some scores so the first one flavor
flavor or taste
out of ten sean
the three oh he doesn't like it he
doesn't like it he recommended it and he
doesn't like it no he doesn't like it i
didn't recommend it i recommend it out
of spite
recommendation of the podcast and we
welcome it sean yeah thank you
something here i um
we don't have grape flavoured gum in
britain do we we tend to do kind of mint
a strawberry
possibly what else would it be that's a
classic it's just juicy really you want
mint but grape is not common so i quite
like the grape flavour because it's not
common i'm gonna give it i'm gonna give
it a 6.8
yeah william i think um
if i had to choose
well you have to choose i do but if i
had to choose a flavor for america that
sums up america for me it's either
cherry or grape right so i think this is
quite an american flavor
and i like the flavor and it's intense
when you start biting it
i'm going to give it an 8.2 oh he likes
it yeah it's a flame it's a good flavor
bubble gum he likes it short now
aesthetics that's the obviously the
product itself but also the package
which i think
i'm quite taken with the packaging
quite like if i was a little boy and my
you know favorite uncle got me this in a
big bag and i think wow that is a lot of
gum it's a lot of gum i know so it feels
like tobacco you're ripping
off i feel like a real man sticking it
in your mouth
yeah i like that as well i like this
this except i don't like this the way it
sticks to it
and once you know
as the powder is the way it keeps it
just from sticking it i don't think i've
got enough powder here sure so i would
so do i go first on this please sean i
think it's a fair
if i'm allowed to use a decimal i'll go
10.9
well it's out of 10. oh you give it an
extra nine points what well let me can
you have a 6.9 of course you can can you
have any can you have an eight point
nine yeah you can have anything up to
ten minutes yeah why can't you have a
ten point then why can't you have a ten
point well the maximum is ten it's like
saying i'm a hundred and ten percent and
yeah you can be 110 and
if you want to break the rules 10.9 okay
wow
he loves the aesthetic
i think i mean it's impressive that
they've made something look kind of like
chewing tobacco it's not
incredibly attractive as a food item no
maybe little kids are in there no but
the front the front panel the front yeah
the front gets a little extra oh you've
got a different cover mine's blue shawn
see
yeah my wife got me the original which
is the least appealing
okay well i'm going to give it
aesthetics i'm going to give it a
uh
excuse me i'm going to give it a
a 5.7 oh it doesn't like look at that
much really
um well that's a taste more than the
look yeah i do i like the taste i like
that they've tried to do something what
they've done is not very aesthetically
pleasing
but it does do the job of what it's
supposed to do yeah i feel as if you're
eating chewed tobacco yeah so i'm going
to give her a 7.4
okay
now we move into the slightly surreal
uh
scoring
uh what do we call it we call this
usefulness yeah but what is it category
category how useful is this how useful
is it sean
can you use it for anything else apart
from bubblegum
could you put it in a casserole no that
would be my answer could you plug a leak
with it but maybe i don't think it'd be
good for plugging leaks it's kind of
kind of a slippery vibe to it
say for instance you are in an old
building that used to be a newspaper
print and you found it a bit drastic
could you stretch it across the bottom
of the the door possible
add a bubble gum
it's quite good for blowing bubbles as
well some bubble gum they say it's
bubble gum but you can't get bubbles out
of it this is quite good for bubbles let
me see your biggest one definitely a
good bubble gum
go hang on
go if if you're saying if you're saying
if you're saying that you want to stop
someone from getting mouth cancer from
tobacco chewing tobacco it accomplishes
that 100 percent well that is
actually pretty useful i think this is a
podcast that wants to establish to stop
people from getting sick as opposed to
getting more sick yeah yeah but i don't
know if
i mean
if you're going to have kale or spinach
or
bigly chew
you know i'd go with the killer the
spinach so i just don't i want to make
sure the scale is
you know calibrated correctly um i would
say it's usefulness
um
it's really designed to make children
happy and i think it does that well for
the children who have it i don't know if
it causes
cavities or not um
it's current iteration it says it only
has
two grams of sugar
i'm not sure what that powdery stuff
yeah i'll give it a six what the section
should bang on six
i'm gonna demote it a little bit because
i can't see any other real uses apart
from what it's doing and it's quite
useful as a bubble gum
i'm giving it a i'm giving it a solid
five
well
i i was going to give it a very low very
low score because it is just a bubble
gum but then sean did say
as a replacement for true tobacco
lovely that is quite useful i'll give
that a six point eight
fantastic well sean
big link
what position did you play
in baseball
second base and i was a short relief
pitcher hello there's a joke because i'm
sure but um shortly picture means you
only come in for one inning um and throw
up throw the ball well it depends on how
fast you get them out but yeah i loved
baseball i was very much like rudy
did not have a lot of baseball talent
but i
was so passionate about it that um
yeah give it your all my favorite thing
about baseball is that everyone still
dresses like they're in the 1950s mm-hmm
they've never updated that at all i
think that's brilliant i think everybody
you know it's a big day in baseball
today in american baseball what is it
today this morning is that the
the um
the national league has
changed the name of clubs from the uh
cleveland indians
to the cleveland guardians because
indians is uh culturally
um offensive right i saw that america
i'm sorry i'm surprised
yeah that's correct yeah that's a big
deal there's that's in the baseball
world that's a big deal aren't they
doing that with the washington post i
think as well because that was they had
another the redskins yeah they should
change the redskins name for sure they
need to change all those names that are
that seem like they were complimentary
because they were aggressive but are
actually kind of offensive yeah so it's
hard when you fall in love with
something as a kid if you were a kid and
you were on the cleveland indians and
they made the movie major league with
the tomahawk chop you know
like that's our olay right yeah that's
not a that's not good that's bad you
can't do that anymore my favorite thing
about baseball which i think was said by
a stand-up comedian at one point but i
can't remember who
was he said george carlin oh was it
where he said everyone's just trying to
get home the point of the game is just
to get someone that's really low trying
to get home
yeah
football's about getting over to the
grid yard line with something rather
with its tactics and strategy and all
this stuff baseball everyone wants to go
home yeah it is colin it is judge cannon
that's brilliant
your speech there you almost did your
speech from rudy
i was getting all excited there yeah the
first we're gonna go inside outside
inside and outside we're gonna get him
on the run boys once we get on the
runway keep on the rubber go go go go
we're not gonna stop until we get across
that goal line today's a day we're gonna
win boys what do you say they can't lick
us
you know what you guys should do you
guys should do uh abbott costello you
should do um who's on first oh who's on
first to be great we could learn that
right yes oh my god you guys would be
hilarious because
you have the extra added layer of not
sure
actually i want to hear you do it right
now i don't know all of it i don't know
how to do it no you have to look
all right well you're not going to know
we'll get that for you we'll do it
because it would have have the extra
added benefit of of uh the kind of
transatlantic confusion
on top of the
uh dopiness oh my god it would be so
good now i really have to hear that i
really really want to work on it yeah
we'll do it we'll do it
well sean it's been fantastic having you
on the show
we will of course as we have an open
invitation to come back whenever you
want we'd love to have you in the studio
we understand that obviously covert
restrictions you've been very smart and
very conservative to protect yourself
and your family
but um
yeah man hopefully i want to know that
when i come in
to be on the show
we can talk about mundane things or
seemingly mundane things let's do it you
give us a list event you want to talk
about we'll talk about that otherwise
we'll bring up mundane things for sure
and you can have scotch rabbit yeah
we'll make a promise to each other when
you come into the studio that we will
not talk about lord of the rings the
entire time that you're here and that
will allow us to talk about the mundane
that's what i'm saying i think we had to
put the lay down the marker of lord of
the rings but now i want to because i
love your show i love listening to you
guys and the way you just talk about
simple life things makes everything
feel more important
uh so i want i want to feel that feeling
oh cool so um yeah we would do anything
for you you know that sean i just made
some wisey's um
uh frying pan
big league chew do you want to maybe
promote the usefulness of it now yeah
i've made that not 6.8 anymore bring up
the the scores again
it's an 8.5 nice bills nice so is there
a total is there a total well oh yes
there's a total there's a total out of
30. yeah but uh yeah as of yet we don't
we don't kind of top up the scores that
gets totted up for us
one day one of us will die me and tom
and then we'll put down all the scores
on us it'll be published yeah
in lieu of a uh of a proper
uh
uh what do you call it not a eulogy but
yeah yeah
yeah would they call it in a
oh my god do you know the first letter
does it rhyme with something
dinosaur
is it a whale is it a whale a helicopter
um
well sean it's been lovely to have you
on the show we love you you you're
obviously always welcome um
it was great chatting to you mate yeah
enjoy the rest of your day love your
family give our love to love you guys
we'll see you soon we'll see you soon
all right start sean stay safe bye bye
see me
what do you think of that dom i loved it
it was good one i love the interview
half as much as i love sean because i
love sean quite a lot i gave the
interview a solid 89 percent of love but
i'll give sean 110
you gave him 110 well done that yeah
yeah i think sean's a brilliant guy and
you i never get sick of listening to him
tell stories and stuff because he's good
at it yeah he's good at it he's a good
actor as well yeah
i'm looking forward to see what he does
next yeah me too because uh
there's a few actors that i really look
forward to their stuff you're one of
them thanks bills sean astin's another
one that's very sweet yeah i love sean's
stuff too i mean we touched on it very
uh briefly there but when i was flying
over to
excuse me new zealand the people that i
knew were involved obviously you i was a
fantastic fan of you of course you will
uh orlando uh-huh elijah yep liv ah and
sean and i don't think anyone else was
fully confirmed at that point okay and i
remember being so excited to meet
the guy
from who was mikey in the goonies and
also i'd seen
you'd seen you had seen
you had seen
i'd seen rudy right i'd seen it and i'd
loved it
didn't you have like really bad jet lag
when you watched rudy so it was a little
kind of surreal
but i fell in love with it i loved it
yeah i thought sean was brilliant in it
well that was really great
great to chat with sean he's being very
uh mindful and cautious with his family
about covid but he did promise us that
when he's out of a place of being
so careful and uh considerate of his
family he'll come and sit in the studio
with us and we will not talk about lord
of the rings we might mention it we
might mention but we'll talk about other
things as well like literature and
theater and art yes and
string theory what is it
so guys get in touch with us
rate review and subscribe to the podcast
the friendship on you can find us on
youtube as well you can email us at the
friendship on castmedia.com that's cass
with the k
and
don't forget if you leave a review take
a picture of it takazan
and we might stick it up on our
instagram or read them out here on the
friendship onion you can also leave us a
voice message at
speakpipe.com the forward slash
friendship onion the forward slash
probably not forward slash the french
bunny and also we have a playlist the
french onion on spotify of all of the
songs that we're wondering whether you
guys think are funky as well so come
subscribe to that because each week we
add an extra song we might add a billy
joelle song in tribute to mr sean
samuel who's gamjee i think uptown girl
is his funkiest song oh yes
what a lovely talent
[Music]
do you know i think the woman who played
the uptown girl in the video
and his wife right
for 10 points i thought it was monika
from friends
no she was in dancing in the dark with
bruce springsteen and she married bruce
springsteen no
she the lady who is an uptown girl
married billy joelle which is nice
because he's just a mechanic covered in
grease he's a greased monkey and she's
walking past your door yeah that was not
what we're talking about though are you
sure well we could talk about that but
do you remember the name of the model
and what
an uptown girl yeah walked past the kind
of a new york chicago type
hot steamy night where they're all
fixing uh fixing tires i need to pick up
my [ __ ] bird or something twiggy
twiggy was famous in the early 60s did
she go with one of the friends i don't i
think you're getting a bit confused
aren't you carry on it's billy joelle
billy joelle's wife john put us out of
our misery
libor hang on
hang on
chrissy brinkley well done ten points
beautiful amazingly wonderful woman and
they married
and i think that song
you'll always be a woman to me
he thinks you're a [ __ ] and he thinks
you're a [ __ ] and she thinks you're a
gossip but you're always a woman
i think that's about chrissy brinkley
are you sure no no i think that's about
the one from friends is that about
courtney love from friends no the one
that sings the thing about the cat
ow right phoebe smelly dog smelly duck
right we've got to go hey guys we'll see
you next week why wouldn't we on the
friendship onion toodles adios
you